[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après leur très bon début en championnat
de France de football les Toulousains
maillot foncés ont connu sur leur
terrain face au bordeled et lendemain
qui déchante il est vrai qu'on a très
peu joué au football sur la pelouse
ensoleillée du Stadium municipal
transformé pour les 3/ de la partie en
ring de
combat pas une attaque qui ne se soit
terminé comme cela et il ne s'agit là
que d'un petit
horde cette mê confuse devant les BU
bordelais se termine par un drame le
Toulousain ma est touché à la
tête résultat commotion cérébrale ça
c'est du sport ça ne suffit pas à calmer
les esprits l'arbitre est complètement
débordé malgré son air placide les
agressions reprennent de plus belle tant
d'un côté que de l'autre ce n'est plus
un match c'est une bataille de rue et il
n'y a pas de raison pour que ça s'arrête
et dire que 20000 spectateurs ont payé
pour voir cela et pour ne rien arranger
un incident d'arbitrage remet le feu au
poudre les Bordelais certes n'ont pas
joué très élégamment mais ils ne sont
tout de même pas responsables si
l'arbitre leur a accordé un but sur coup
franc parfaitement justifi ils étaient
là tout de même pour essayer de gagner
leur match et malgré la colère des
Toulousains le résultat est sans appel 1
à0 pour Bordeaux mais de toute façon
zéro de conduite pour les deux
[Applaudissements]
équipes nouveau pas en avant dans les
relations franco-allemandes monsieur
George Pompidou a présidé avec Monsieur
EEC ministre allemand de la famille et
de la jeunesse à l'installation de
l'Office franco-allemand pour la
jeunesse dont le but est d'organiser des
échanges de jeunes entre les deux pays
le général de Gaulle en recevant à
l'Élysée les membres du nouvel office a
salué cette création qui intéresse
quelques 25 millions de jeunes Français
et Allemands et dont l'action commencera
dès cet
Iver le lac toplitz dans les Alpes
autrichiennes va-t-il enfin livrer son
secret le gouvernement autrichien vient
en effet d'y envoyer une équipe de
chercheurs muni d'un matériel technique
considérable et de déclarer zone
interdite les abords du lac une légende
Tenas désigne en effet le lact tooplitz
comme l'endroit où auraiit été immergés
les fabuleux trésors nazi et certains
décès suspects survenus à cet endroit
n'ont fait qu'ajouter aux
hypothèses le célèbre spectacle d'olid
on Ice avec ses danseuses évoluant sur
la patinoire s'est terminé cette fois en
tragédie au colisé d'Indianapolis aux
États-Unis où le spectacle s'achevait un
quart d'heure plus tard qu'à l'ordinaire
un quart d'heure fatal une énorme
explosion venue du sous-sol et branla
l'immense vaisseau pendant que les loges
et les balcons littéralement soufflaient
étit projeté avec leurs occupants
jusqu'au sein des blocs de ciment
arrachés par l'explosion retombaient
dans la foule pendant qu'une flamme
gigantesque jaillissait du sous-sol
pendant que les danseuses quittaient les
coulisses dans leur costumes de scène un
spectacle tragique s'étalait dans
l'arène des décombres on dégageait des
blessés et des
[Musique]
morts des 6000 spectateurs qui
applaudissaient tout à l'heure
385 portaient des blessures plus ou
moins graves et le bilan funèbre était
lourd c'est 62 cadavres en effet que les
équipes de secours alignaient sur la
[Musique]
piste la conférence de bamaco a réussi
du moins a-telle abouti à une signature
le roi Hassan 2 et le président Ben B
accueill tour à tour par le président du
Mali modibita et le nus devent parvenir
grâce à l'intervention de ces derniers à
un accord de cess le feu après de jours
de négociation au cours desquel les deux
adversaires refusèrent d'abord de se
rencontrer l'action des deux médiateurs
fit prévaloir une formule qui pouvait
obtenir l'assentiment du Maroc et de
l'Algérie c'est donc cette formule que
signè Ben B d'un air grave le RO Hassan
d'un air
souriant et ce lare poigné de main
entretemps les forces marocaines avaient
repris au nord de Tindouf le poste
d'ouelchar occupé par une unité
algérienne les adversaires laissèrent
sur le terrain des morts et des blessés
et 40 algériens furent faits prisonniers
avec leurs
[Musique]
armes d'autres actions du même genre
devaient se produire bien après l'heure
fixée pour le cesselffeu et le nom de
figig situé en terre marocaine emporté
par les Algériens puis reprise par les
Marocains a fait peser pendant 3 jours
une nouvelle interrogation sur la fin
des
combats pour la 7e fois le 27 octobre au
cœur de saon un bon s'était donné la
mort par le feu en signe de protestation
contre le régime du président de
godinem
cette image effroyable devenait la
préface du coup d'État qui devait
emporter le
[Musique]
régime quelques jours plus tard en effet
le gouvernement de di sombrait sous les
coups de l'armée révolté di lui-même et
son frère l'homme fort du régime trouv
la mort dans les acôtés sanglants de ce
coup
d'État voici les premières images tourné
après la rédition de la Gard spéciés
président qui résista une journée aux
forces des 16 généraux qui conduisirent
le mouvement et qui se sont emparés du
pouvoir la lutte a été dure en certains
endroit et certains immeubles défendus
avec acharnement ont été attaqués au
canon et au
[Musique]
mortiers devant le palais présidentiel
longuement défendu et saccagé après les
combats une foule considérable a
manifesté son contentement devant les
gardes prisonniers et les vainqueurs
satisfait un nouveau régime prend donc
la place de Diem dont le buste blessé
contemple la ruine de son pouvoir
nouveau régime qui sa dès la première
heure donné pour programme l'Union
national et la lutte contre le
[Musique]
communisme le chakra
rajou ce pic de plus de 6000 m dans la
Cordière des Indes restait inviolet ses
pentes abruptes presque verticales la
glace et la neige qui le recouvrent par
endroit en toute saison semblaient
s'opposer à tout escalade c'est pourtant
son ascension tenté et réussi par une
équipe que conduisait Claude Maillard
Lionel Teré et Guido Magon que nous
restiue les images de jean-jacqu langpin
qui faisait partie de
l'expédition la dernière étape fut la
plus dure c'est celle dont vous suivez
les difficiles progrès l'apreté du décor
la difficulté de l'entreprise le danger
toujours présent et le courage des
hommes se passe de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parole une neige instable des corniches
sans cesse prêtes à s'écrouler des
parois de roches lisses qui ne donnent
aucune prise des apies à 80°r les
alpinistes ont tout connu au cours de
cette ascension où le moindre faux pas
signifia la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mort
[Musique]
et pourtant dans un dernier assaut qui
Dua à 3 jours l'étonnante prouesse
sportive est réalisée à plus de 6000 m
dominant une mer de pics enneigé
l'équipe française fait flotter son
drapeau au grand vent des
Simes chakra Raju un nom de plus au
palmarès de l'alpinisme
[Musique]
français le match de la confirmation
Parc des Princes à Paris devant les
Suisses commence bien très bien même
pour les footballeurs français les deux
équipes jouent maillot foncé mais on
reconnait les Français leur B donc début
de match extrêmement favorable à la
France durant 45 minutes les Suisses
sont à l'épreuve et l' s'attente au pire
lorsque le petit AER gauche Buron marque
le
premier
un premier but qui semble ouvrir la voie
à toute une série d'autres but d'autant
que l'autre aier français lèche le
benjamin du match il a 18 ans marque une
seconde
fois on s'attente à une catastrophe pour
la Suisse et on a tort deè mi-temps
revirement total de la situation les
meneurs de jeu de l'équipe de France en
tête
s'effondre le résultat ne se fait pas
attendre Suisse marque à son tour 2 à 1
et comme un malheur n'arrive pas seul
l'arrière gauche de l'équipe de France
blessé quitte le terrain à 10 contre 11
plus question pour les Français de faire
autre chose que de résister mais ils ne
peuvent pas éviter le match
[Applaudissements]
nul c'est un curieux sport qu'impose au
brav pou américaines les impératifs de
la productivité car c'est bien de
production 2 à la chaîne qu'il s'agit
dans ce toulaer modèle de Californie
élevé à la dignité d'usine comme dans
n'importe quelle usine l'automation est
reine première opération distribution de
la matière
[Musique]
première pas de perte les surplus sont
récupérés 2è opération récupération par
tapis roulant toujours des produit fini
la production des œufs en Amérique a
vraiment atteint son plus haut degré de
rendement on comprend devant une telle
productivité la guerre du
poulet
[Musique]
les armes se sont tues sur le front du
désert à figig mê où le conflit
algéro-marocain avait semblé reprendre
après le cessfeu déterminé par l'accord
de bamaco les forces marocaines ramènent
à son climat de paix de paix armée tout
de même l'oasis hier encore troublé par
les
[Musique]
combats c'est pour constater le respect
du cessfeu qu'une commission des Nations
unies dans laquelle 10 nations étaient
représenté est venu jusqu'à figig en
compagnie du général marocainou
sur sur toute la ligne de ce qui fut le
front du désert le calme rgne
[Musique]
désormais voici les images tourné dans
le feu de l'action lors du coup d'État
de et qui mon dans leloqu brutalité les
phases de cette insurrection les forces
insurg converant vers le palais
présidentiel au milieu des coup de fe
des incendies c'est l'atmosphère de
révolution et de guerre de rue de cette
fin du
régime
[Musique]
le soir du 2 novembre le buste mutilé du
président sa garde prisonnière après une
résistance acharnée les vainqueurs
portés en triomphe par une foule
enfiévré affirm la victoire totale de la
jeinte des généraux cette victoire
n'allait pas sans le cortège habituel de
débordement populaire désordre pillage
et
incendie
[Applaudissements]
l'opposition au régime déchu a pris ce
jour-là toutes les formes acclamation
pour les bonses libéré des prisons et
outrage au buste de Madame new jeté au
ruisseau mais depuis saon est rentré
dans le
calme quand un cosmonaute épouse une
cosmonaute tout se passe comme pour le
commun des mortels c'est ce qu'ont
démontré à Moscou Adrian Nikolayev et
Valentina tchkova à ce détail près que
la noce s'est retrouvé au palais des
réceptions dont Monsieur K a fait les
honneurs aux deux belles mamans très
émues avant de lever son verre au
bonheur des époux voilà en tout cas une
raison de croire que la race des
cosmonaut ne s'éteindra
[Musique]
pas mieux informé mieux défendu contre
la tuberculose tel est le thème
qu'évoque le nouveau timbre qui vient
d'être remis au ministre de la Santé
publique à l'occasion de l'ouverture de
la 33e campagne nationale contre le
terrible fléo un fléo qui aujourd'hui
100 ans après la naissance de Calmet
inventeur avec Guérin du BCG tue encore
six fois plus en France qu'au Danemark
où le vaccin est appliqué
systématiquement depuis longtemps ce
sera le mérite de la nouvelle campagne
de rappeler à tous qu'il existe un
vaccin efficace et simple et qu'il est
criminel de le négliger par passivité ou
par
[Musique]
ignorance
la boéie pour beaucoup ce nom n'évoque
pas autre chose qu'une rue célèbre de
Paris une de ces rues aujourd'hui
encombré de voitures dont les trottoirs
sont voués au shopping et sans doute
assez peu d'entre ces flameneuses se
doute seulement qu'il exista un certain
Étienne de la Bessie né à Sarla en 1530
et mort 33 ans plus tard voici justement
400 ans c'est ce nom qui unit étonnant
jumelage l'une des plus fameuses artères
parisiennes à la petite cité
périgourdine endormie dans un passé dont
elle ne renit rien ni les jolis toit de
l'OSE ni les poivrières d'angle ni les
vieux Porsches qui ont peut-être vu
enfant ou jeune homme celui qui devait
passer comme un Météor dans le ciel
littéraire de son temps et dont le nom
n'a surtout survécu que parce qu'il fut
l'ami de choix de Montaigne ce qui lui
inspira cette définition de l'amitié si
l'on me presse de dire pourquoi je
t'aimais Je sens que cela ne peut
s'exprimer qu'en répondant parce que
c'était lui parce que c'était moi c'est
dans cette ville silencieuse où tout
choses et gens est presque resté tel
qu'il le connut de la lanterne des morts
au marché auois qu'il est sans doute
plus facile de retrouver cet homme qui
promettait tant et qui mourut si jeune
sans remplir les promesse de son unique
ouvrage le discours sur la servitude
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
volonté
peut-être écrivit-il quelques chapitrees
de son œuvre entre les murs de cette
maison où il naquis et qui abrite
aujourd'hui étrange destin la Caisse
d'Épargne 400 ans après sa disparition
on l'imagine ce jeune pensif comme l'un
des flambeaux trop vite éteint d'une
époque à d'idée comme un esprit qui eut
ouvert des portes sur l'avenir il reste
dans son inachèvement comme le disait
Montaigne une âme qui montrait un beau
visage à à tout
[Musique]
sens ce latin du miracle 24 heur après
le sauvetage de tris mineurs dans la
mine de pine la tour de forage s'est
remise en action dans la nuit 4 km plus
loin un forrage d'exploration avait
permis de repérer 11 mineurs encore
prisonniers à 56 m de nouveau l'espoir
régnait sur la mine un deuxè forage plus
important fut réalisé il permettre de
descendre des vivres et du matériel de
première
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
urgence le trè forage celui du sauvetage
était aménagé pour permettre le va et
vien de la
nacelle les 11 hommes seraient sauvés la
pose des tubes protecteurs n'était plus
qu'une affaire de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
routine et c'est sous le regard d'une
foule muette d'émotion qu'apparaissait
enfin sorti de la nacelle d'acier le
premier escapé he cull paire de 10
enfants minute bouleversante où chacun
semblait aidé du regard la silhouette
titubante au visage creusé d'un homme
qui avait passé 14 jours en muré
vivant puis de 5 en 5 minutes c'était un
nouveau mineur que la nacelle rendait à
la lumière crue un nouveau rescapé
qu'une famille des larmes de joie plein
les yeux
attendait mais les familles devaient
encore attendre chacun de ces hommes
durement éprouvé par 369 heur de
clustration ne pourrait que lentement
revenir à la vie normale dans une
chambre
d'hôpital en 1 heure c'était
fini et la joie n'a pu s'empêcher
d'éclater à P où les drapeaux sont
restés en berne car il y a tout de même
morts
les spectateurs parisiens du Palais des
Sport ont eu la chance d'applaudir un
futur champion du monde des poisplumes
âgé de 20 ans à peine ce grand champion
de demain c'est le Panaméen ismaë Laguna
en culotte
[Applaudissements]
blanche son adversaire le Nigérien RAF
King qui n'est pourtant pas le premier
boxeur venu a été contraint de
s'incliner au point après un combat
après
sévère Launac est encore un boxeur à
l'état P autrement dit un boxeur qui
ignore TF celle du métier utilise toute
la gamme des coups les plus simples mais
avec quelle vitesse et quelle
efficacité rafw King malgré son ardeur
ne peut que s'incliner devant un tel
adversaire et personne en définitive ne
conteste la victoire du jeune panaméen
Laguna avec lui la Nouvelle Vague
s'apprête à prendre la relève il était
temps les bisons qui furent pendant des
siècles les rois de la prairie
canadienne ont été vers la fin du siècle
dernier sur le point de disparaît
heureusement le gouvernement canadi a
pris des mesures de protection sévèr qui
ont permis de reconstituer un troupeau
de 14000 bisons qui vivent en liberté
dans leur habitat
[Musique]
naturel chaque année à l'automne dans le
but de surveiller la croissance et la
santé du troupeau les équipes
forestières avec leurs hélicoptères se
mettent en devoir de rassembler la masse
des bisons et de diriger leur tribus
vers les centres de préservation de la
race où sont réunis enclos et
laboratoire
en Autriche les recherches commencé
voici bientôt un mois pour retrouver au
fond du lac topitz le mystérieux trésor
que les nazis coulè à l'heure de la
défaite ont produit un premier résultat
la caméra de télévision sous-marine a
permis de repérer au milieu de
différents débris une caisse que les
hommes grenouilles ont réussi à
dégager comme certains l'avaient
pronostiqué il s'agit de fauses
banquenotes britanniques que les nazis
avaient fabriqué et dont il se
promettaient d'inonder le monde afin de
causer à l'Angleterre la plus grave des
crises financières voici donc résolu un
premier mystère mais le lactoplitz en
recelle peut-être
d'autres à Saigon le nouveau
gouvernement vietnamien s'est installé
les principales figures en sont le
Président Monsieur ngyen nocto et le
génér van min qui fut l'organisateur du
coup d'étail qui est l'homme fort du
nouveau régime le chef de la jeunte des
généraux pense que la première tâche du
gouvernement et de regagner la confiance
du pays pour battre les communistes du
Viet Kong la population a réservé un
accueil chaleureux au bons libérés ces
mesures jointes à la volonté de ne pas
se livrer à des représailles devrai
contribuer à une rapide stabilisation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
politique à la fois plignante et accusée
la délégation algérienne conduite par
Monsieur bouteflica s'est rencontré à
Addis Abeba avec la délégation marocaine
devant l'Assemblée des États africains
réunie sous la présidence du Négus a
etcier et de Monsieur doudoutiam
ministre des Affaires étrangères du
Sénégal les 32 états de l'organisation
de l'Union africaine ont à donné suite
aux accord de bamaco et doivent selon
les paroles du ngus mettre tout en œuvre
pour assurer une solution pacifique au
conflit
[Musique]
algéro-marocain à Paris c'est la saison
des prix littéraires qui ou chez où
fidèle à une tradition solide les
académiciens goncour sét réunis pour
déjeuner et pour
voter et comme à l'habitude phipis
l'étouffement pour annoncer le
résultatribué au 6
tour quand la par jeanmust leio Laura du
prix renudo a partagé avec lui cette
journée de
gloire
il suffit de passer devant un lycée de
Paris pour s'en apercevoir la mode fait
aujourd'hui partie des préoccupations
des moins de 15 ans à l'âge où leur
grandes sœur n'y songeait guerre des
générations de lycéenne marquent leur
goût de façon déterminée elles ont leur
mode qui parfois même déteint sur celle
des grands cette saison elle raffolle de
Bonet tricoté à ponpon par exemple
certaines la sortisent à une veste
écossaise le BET tricoté a lui aussi des
quant aux chaussettes noires elles font
fureur la casquette Sherlock Holmes
connaît toujours un succès marqué comme
la longue écharpe de ton et l'on voit
apparaître les guêtres
[Musique]
longues à 14 ans maintenant on sait ce
qu'on
[Musique]
veut ce qui est arrivé à saintternin est
déjà arrivé ailleurs en Bretagne ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'on voit
les gendarmes enquêter dans la lande et
les habitants de la petite paroisse du
Finistère ne sont pas les seuls à se
poser des
questions cette fois on a volé le Père
Éternel c'est une statue d'un calvaire
du 15e siècle qui a disparu un calvaire
en plein champ voilà qui n'a pas
facilité l'enquête d'autant qu'ici les
langues sont parfois longues à se délier
monsieur constaté la
disparition il a longtempê ça fait 3
mois demi
oui mais j'ai tardé un petit peu à avant
de prévenir personne quoi le calvaire
avait donc intéressé de façon très
particulière certains touristes un
connaisseur sans aucun doute alors il
m'a dit comme ceci ben il est beau ce
CALV j'ai dit oui parce que ça vaut ça
vaut beauoup tout me dit il m'a parlé de
10 millions voà alors moi je lui ai dit
comme ceci ben si ça vaut 10 millions
moi puisque c'est sur mes droits moi je
vais prendre ce CALV là je vais la
démolir al comme ça j'aurais 10 Milon
alors il a fait un sourire
quoi c'est ainsi qu'on est plus loin de
croire en Bretagne que sur les
innombrables calvaires les précieuses
statues sont devenu depuis un an la
proie d'un véritable gang qui opérerait
pour le compte de collectionneur si bien
que tous les villages tremblent pour
leur patrimoine artistique qui est comme
chacun sait un des plus riches de France
la seule église de saintnin renferme de
véritables trésors d'art ancien bien
capable de faire rêver des connaisseurs
indélicats
[Musique]
va-t-on mettre tout cela sous
clé ne sont pas enfermés comme dit la
presse dans des coffres fort non il
faudrait pas d'ailleurs ceses d'artre
visible de tout le monde c'est c'est un
trésor pour bien sûr pour la paroisse
mais les paroissiens sont fiers quand
les touristes passent et viennent voir
ses uvres dans
l'Église c'est bien là le drame
aujourd'hui village breton chaque nuit
au bout de chemin désert des calvaires
sont là des statues sans âge des pièces
uniques sont à l'intérieur d'église dont
les portes battent à tout vent et non
pour seule protection que le respect de
chacun il les a défendu pendant des
siècles mais aujourd'hui apparemment il
n'y suffit
[Musique]
plus dans le Finistère les côtes du nord
le morbillan on a enreistré disparition
Nocturn et tout récemment on est allé
jusqu'à voler un mir atterré devant tant
d'audace les vieux Bretons ne veulent
plus croire qu'à l'intervention des
esprits malfaisants certains les vieux
bretonsux bretux qui ne parlent que le
Breton pense que ça ce sont des méf du
Corgan c'est surtout l'oiseau de la mort
qu'on appelle l' breton le nou qu'est-ce
que c'est exactement le Corgan nou le
corigan vous savez c'est mon avis
c'ests les dicton les vieux et la
traduction même du dictionnaire ce sont
des NAS
maléfiques petits des g de bouffons si
vous voulez qui h alors la campagne
Cagne ce soit les cor qui même des mir
puisquon a parlé aussi de vol de
mirz je le pense pas quand même oui il
en est tout de même qu'on ne volera pas
siô
qui aurait pu imaginer le jour de 1953
où John FAL Kennedy épous Jacqueline le
bouvier que 10 ans plus tard cette
radieuse image de bonheur s'effacera
sous une tche de sang que John Kennedy
tomber sous les balles d'un assassin
candidat du parti démocrateé à la
présidence des États-Unis avec Lindon
Johnson pour viceprésident il succédait
à la Maison Blanche
àisener à l'âge de 43
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il inaugurait sa présidence par un
voyage en Europe où sa visite au général
de Gaulle et l'accueil chaleureux de
Paris préludait à la rencontre de
krutchov à Vienne rencontre qui ne
provoquait pas toutefois la détente
[Musique]
escomtée son voyage le conduisait
également à bonne auprès du chancelier
adoer voyage au cours duquel la
population allemande lui faisait une
sorte de TR
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais deux crises majeures allaient
secouer l'Amérique et le monde l'affaire
de Cuba d'abord l'installation à 250 km
des côtes américaines de rampes à
missile soviétique allait mettre le
monde à deux pas de la guerre Kennedy su
prendre à l'égard de Castro et de ses
alliés l'attitude ferme qui éloigna le
danger une autre crise menaçait le drame
de la ségrégation dont la marche des
Noirs réclamant l'égalité des droits
n'était que signe officiel il eut le
sens humain et généreux dans lequel le
problème doit être réglé il meurt
laissant l'exemple d'un homme qui avec
la confiance du monde libre sut apaiser
les défiances de l'Est et l'image d'une
vie heureuse au milieu d'une famille
heureuse laissant aussi un grand destin
[Musique]
inachevé voici le film de l'attentat qui
a coûté la vie au président Kennedy avec
sa femme Jacqueline il était à Dallas au
cours d'une tournée politique dans le
sud des États-Unis et descendait dans
une voiture découverte la grande rue de
la ville pour gagner le bâtiment où il
devait prononcer un discours devant le
conseil local des citoyens soudain des
coups de feu c'était
[Musique]
l'attentat le tir était parti du 5e
étage d'une grande bâtise où les
policiers découvrirent aussitôt une
carabine à lunett arme d'une précision
redoutable puisque le président avait
été tué d'une seule balle dans la tête
bientôt après on arrêtait un suspect Lee
Harve Oswald qui tira sur les policier
venu l'arrêter tuant l'un
d'eux dans les rues l'émotion était à
son comble l'annonce de la mort du jeune
président touchait au plus profond l'âme
populaire et cette émotion devait en un
minimum de temps s'étendre au monde
entier aux Nations Unies le président
levait la séance en signe de deuil et
dans toutes les capitales les
gouvernements décrétent un deuil
officiel le président était mort sur la
table d'opération 25 minutes après
l'attentat son corps devait le soir même
être transféré à Washington où
accompagné de Jacqueline Kennedy il
était conduit à la Maison Blanche avec
les honneurs
[Musique]
fun
de partout parvenaient les témoignages
d'un deil universel et le général de
Gaulle décidait de se rendre à
Washington pour y assister au funérail
du président assassiné il s'y
retrouverait avec les chefs d'État et
les chefs de gouvernement de quelques 50
[Musique]
nations à la Maison Blanche les
personnalités rendaient hommage à la
dépouille de John Kennedy président
novateur et courageux qui sut être ferme
à des heures difficiles et qui laissera
le souvenir d'un grand homme
[Musique]
d'État à Paris ellisabeth Bayon une
jeune artiste en tapisserie a vu sa
vocation encouragée par un chèque de
10000 francs avec elle devant un
aréopage de célébrité 23 jeunes qui ont
manifesté leur volonté de suivre la voix
qui les appelait ont reçu ce même
encouragement en offrant une nouvelle
fois à des jeunes gens et des jeunes
filles le moyen de réaliser une ambition
que peut-être il n'aurait pu réaliser
faute d'argent la fondation de la
vocation créée et animée par Monsieur
blestin Blanchet continue d'assumer sa
belle
[Musique]
tâche àce dans le palais des congrès
dont les abords transformés en galerie
d'exposition présenté les dernières
réalisations françaises s'est déroulé la
journée de la 5e
République Monsieur Michel Debray et
Mondon messsieur Jox perfit 23 ministres
réunis sous la présidence d'André mer
avec 3000 délégués venu de toutes les
régions de France ont écouté le discours
du premier ministre monsieur George
Pompidou qui adressé le bilan de
l'action gouvernementale depuis 5 ans et
indiquer le sens des efforts qui seront
fait dans l'avenir nous travaillons
a-t-il dit et nous continuerons de
travailler
[Musique]
Ann chancelier depuis un mois qui est l
un homme qui aime toujours lire des
livres d'économie dans l'intimité de son
bureau où des photographies évo le
canonnier de 1914 et le fils du Mercier
qu'il
futber un homme aussi qui dans cette
maison du lac de to a à jouer les
grand-pères des
bonnets
loin des débats parlementaires il s'est
réservé un cadre familial où il aime
retrouver une épouse une fille des
petits
enfants l'homme public on avait commencé
à le mieux connaître en septembre 1949
quand le gouvernement àenoer dans lequel
il était ministre de l'Économie prenait
officiellement en charge le destin de
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest mais l'vart avait
déjà influé sur le destin d'un pays
ruiné par la guerre où tout
de communication comme la nourriture et
sur lequ le régime des restrictions PES
quotidiennement de tout son
poid conseiller économique des autorités
allié il avait mis au point la réforme
monétaire de juin 1948 qui en changeant
la monnaie renversa la situation
économique il pu voir se réaliser ce
qu'on a appelé le miracle économique
allemand
en moins de 10 ans ce fut le retour de
l'abondance et la prospérité de
l'Allemagne étalé aux yeux du
monde depuis il a gardé le goût assez
singulier des visites dans les
marchés lors de sa nomination au poste
de chancelier la jeunesse allemande est
venue le saluer comme le symbole
rassurant de cette prospérité que les
Allemands lui
[Applaudissements]
doient tel est l'homme qui a succédé à
celui qu'on appela aussi le chancelier
de fer et qui vient d'être reçu à Paris
au Palais de l'Élysée le chancelier
herart devait rencontrer pour la
première fois en tant que chef de
gouvernement le Général de Gaulle
rencontre qui a permis aux deux hommes
d'État d'évoquer les problèmes auxquels
sont confronté la France et l'Allemagne
et sur lesquelles ont porté à l'Hôtel
Matignon les conversations avec le
Premier ministre monsieur George
Pompidou autan Europe marchez
comm
[Musique]
au Capitol devant le cercueil de bronze
qui renferme le corps du président
assassiné la première à s'agenouiller ce
sera Jacqueline Kennedy et sa fille de 6
ans Caroline et les mots manquent devant
cette scène d'une émotion
poignante
[Musique]
dehors une foule immense qui pendant des
heures défilera devant le cercueil
apportant un dernier hommage au
président
[Musique]
disparu mais presque à la même heure à
Dallas un nouveau drame imprévisible lui
aussi s'est
[Musique]
déroulé encadré de policiers l'assassin
présumé lioswald était à son tour
victime d'un meurtrier devant les
caméras et les journalistes blessé au
ventre par un certain Jack Ruby lioswald
devait succomber sur la table
d'opération nouveau mystère qui s'ajoute
au mystère de l'attentat
[Musique]
présidentiel l'heure des funérailles
sonnet à Washington
entre ces deux beaux frères le ministre
de la Justice Robert et le sénateur
Edward Jacqueline Kennedy suivra le
convoi funèbre devant les chefs d'État
et les chefs de gouvernement de plus de
50 nations jusqu'à la cathédrale
[Musique]
Saint-Mathieu accompagné de sa fille
Caroline et du petit John Fitgerald dont
le 3e anniversaire tombe justement ce
jourl au son de ce même av Maria qui
accompagna la cérémonie de son mariage
Jacqueline Kennedy va prendre sa place
devant le président Lindon Johnson et
les délégations où l'on reconnaît la
reine de Grèce le roi des Belges le
général de
Gaulle le président lupke et le
chancelier herart y représent
[Musique]
l'Allemagne monsieur krutchov a délégué
son second monsieur
[Musique]
Mikoyan à cette même heure dans le monde
entier tous les hommes de bonne volonté
auront eu une pensée pour cet homme é
pris de justice et d'humanité qui porta
à certaines minutes le destin du
monde avec ses deux enfants Jacqueline
Kennedy va maintenant assister au départ
du cortège vers le cimetière
d'Arlington et c'est l'inoubliable geste
d'un petit garçon orphelin d'hier et qui
salue
[Musique]
au milieu des 126000 tombes où dorment
les grands morts des guerres d'hier John
fitgérald Kennedy reposera mort aussi
dans l'accomplissement de son devoir
mort au combat victime peut-être de
l'action qu'il menait et du sens qu'il
donnait à sa
[Musique]
mission mort comme un soldat sous le feu
comme l'a dit le général de Gaulle pour
son devoir et au service de son pays
laissant un grand
[Musique]
exemple et la flamme allumée par
Jacqueline Kennedy et qui brûlera
désormais sur la tombe du président
assassiné sera le signe que son exemple
restera dans le souvenir comme il
restera dans
[Musique]
l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]